c'est parti pour neuf mois de travaux à
la préfecture des yvelines les services
situés avenue de l'europe à versailles
fermé au public là où plus de 300
personnes transitent chaque jour ils
viennent notamment pour des documents
liés à la route ou des demandes de titre
pour les étrangers le temps des travaux
un important dispositif de substitution
est donc mis en place au programme
plusieurs changements pour la délivrance
d'une carte grise d'un permis de
conduire ou d'un renouvellement de titre
de séjour pour les étrangers inutile de
se déplacer toutes les démarches se
feront par voie postale en téléchargeant
les documents sur le site internet de la
préfecture et d'autres changements sont
aussi à prévoir pour les les militaires
et les pompiers qui veulent des
passeports de mission ça se fera à la
mairie de versailles qui nous a
gracieusement prêté un local
et puis pour d'autres démarches nous
avons donc ouvert réouvert ici l'ancien
hall d'accueil de la préfecture urgent
aux dons pour une partie des démarches
d'étrangers notamment les demandeurs
d'asile ou les demandeurs de premiers
tests de séjour les demandeurs de titres
spéciaux commerçants artistes etc nous
ouvrons également un local rue de
noailles près de la gare des chantiers
pour une autre d'autres types de
démarches et également pour les
personnes qui demandent leur
naturalisation française ou celles qui
veulent un titre de voyage pour leurs
enfants mineurs et quant aux remises de
titre de séjour elles seront faites à la
mairie de trappes qui nous a prêté un
local sécurisé de façon à recevoir les
personnes et ordonné leur titre de
séjour un hall désuet très sonore une
ventilation incorrect il fallait des
conditions plus modernes d'accueil des
premiers travaux de l'architecte
structurer le hall en organisant au
mieux les services et les flux de
circulation
mais pas seulement second travail c'est
la qualité de l'espace avec l'aspect
lumière l'aspect thermique évidemment
faire en sorte que sous la verrière et
qui est un espace très chaud aujourd'hui
nous n'ayons pas ses effets d'apport
thermique et que nous traitons avec des
systèmes de brise soleil et puis dans
les zones au contraire qu'ils sont trop
sombres nous avons des systèmes depuis
lumière que nous implantons de façon à
capter la lumière et avoir un éclairage
naturel qui vient inondé de lumière les
nouveaux espaces réouverture prévue fin
janvier début février 2015